19 is still circulating across the
country
current disease activity indicators from
daily reported cases to laboratory test
positivity indicate decreasing
transmission in many areas
wastewater data are likewise showing
signs of a potential plateau or
post-peak decline in several areas
as our wastewater network and data
continuing to expand the public health
agency of canada together with our
partners has just launched an online
dashboard to display wastewater trends
in select cities across the country
going forward these data will be
increasingly helpful for communicating
signals such as new or increasing
presence of the virus
currently
lagging severity trends such as
hospitalizations are still elevated but
beginning to decline in some
jurisdictions
nevertheless
weeks of covert 19 resurgence including
widespread illness and health care
worker absenteeism has contributed to
prolonged impacts on the health system
with the ba2
sublineage of
omicron predominating and the sars kov2
virus continuing to evolve
the path ahead may not be smooth
but with the warmer weather beginning it
is hoped that with continued caution we
can enjoy a period of lower activity and
some time for recovery
that's why the theme of this year's
mental health week is so fitting as it
focuses on how we can learn and hone our
empathy skills to help each other
through this week's communications
information and resources the canadian
mental health association
encourages us to develop and practice
these skills starting with listening to
one another without judgment that is to
say empathy helps us put ourselves in
someone else's shoes and seek to
understand their point of view
this not only helps us to connect with
and support others it can also help us
regulate our own emotions and reduce
feelings of isolation
the pandemic has impacted our lives in
many ways
with some research suggesting that up to
50 percent of us in canada have
experienced declines in our mental
health during the pandemic
we know that these impacts have affected
certain groups more than others and that
as the pandemic has evolved we have
faced different challenges including now
while many are happy to have measures
easing this can also bring about anxiety
and stress as communities adapt to the
changes
at this time as throughout the pandemic
wellness together canada continues to
offer confidential virtual mental health
and substance use resources
and supports to people of all ages in
canada to date almost 2.3 million people
across canada have used these supports
which are offered at no cost 24 hours a
day 7 days a week
when it comes to mental health every
action counts i urge all people in
canada to do what they can to support
their own mental health and well-being
and that of their family and friends
practicing empathy through an act of
kindness for someone can go a long way
and together we can all help to create
positive change in our schools
workplaces and communities
although we may experience further ups
and downs in the covert 19 trajectory
going forward
maintaining a vaccine plus approach can
keep us prepared and better protected
this means remaining aware of covet 19
activity in your local area and
continuing to take personal precautions
like staying at home if you're
symptomatic or test positive improving
ventilation and continuing to wear a
mask in shared indoor or crowded spaces
when with people you don't live with
always at the core of vaccine plus is
staying up to date with all the vaccine
doses recommended for you
that means a primary series of covert 19
vaccines for everyone 5 years of age or
older and booster doses as recommended
for those aged 12 years or older
as we as we see more activities and
connections in canada and globally other
serious infectious diseases such as
influenza and measles are making a
comeback
canada is reporting increased influenza
activity in recent weeks
and the world health organization have
reported a 79
increase in worldwide measles cases in
the first two months of this year
compared to the same time last year
as these are vaccine preventable
diseases
delays or misvaccinations during the
pandemic in particular is a key factor
in these rising disease trends
no matter what our age we need to keep
vaccinations up to date throughout our
lives
prevention part of your health plan by
checking in with your health provider or
local health care resources thank you
merci
merch
good day everybody
this week's communications
foreign
is
oh
is
booster doses
vaccinations
um
a reminder to use the raised hand
function if you do have a question on
zoom
and we have a hard stop at 12 at noon
actually so uh we're going to take as
many questions as possible always a
priority to members and then alternating
between english and french
dylan robertson winnipeg free press
hi dr town thanks for taking our
questions i'm wondering what the
articulated goal of the booster campaign
is
if the chief medical officers of health
have set a goal in terms of getting a
certain percentage of the population
boosted or if it's something more like
allowing access to all the priority
groups under nasty within a certain
timeline
thank you for that question so the chief
medical officers of hell together
released a statement
quite recently
recommending up-to-date vaccination
based on the recommended
recommendations of the national advisory
committee on
immunization um i think obviously
the mode it was very important for those
in the highest risk groups to get the
boosters
and we know that they're doing quite
well
in terms of the the most seniors of our
population but there's still some gaps
in vaccine coverage for the boosted dose
for those
between 50 and
say 69 years of age
can
do a lot better of course nasty also
recommends now strongly recommends that
anyone 18
years of age or higher go and get a
booster
um and
even if you got infected you can wait
three months and get your booster
good stuff um i didn't hear an
articulated target there so i'm not sure
if there is one but i'm also wondering
about the prevalence of long covid uh
public health ontario put out some
pretty scary numbers in terms of how
many people get symptoms that would be
classified as long coveted i wanted to
know what your understanding is of how
likely someone who gets infected today
is going to end up with long covid and
if you feel like that risk is
articulated enough in the booster
communication campaigns
thank you for that question and that's a
very important question
i think we are still trying to
understand long covered
more including the prevalence of
long-covered post infection
and there's various estimates
i think that at the who
you know estimates the earlier estimates
puts put it at 10 to 20 percent but we
know that
more recent estimates
have put it at maybe as high as 50
percent
for those who have been infected with
covert 19.
we also don't understand enough perhaps
about how the different variants can
impact long covered
so there's much research
to remains to be done so one of the um
first things that the the public health
agency together with statistics canada
is doing is a survey that's ongoing
right now to try and get a much broader
population level
view of the prevalence of long-covered
or post-covert condition
the cihr is launching
or has been doing supporting research
and also got some recent support in the
recent budget of 20 million dollars to
continue doing more research in this
area
so i think
um
the in summary though
even uh now
we probably anticipate that the impact
of long covert is going to be quite
substantial
and there's a there's a huge range of
symptoms that people are trying to
understand there's over 100 of them
there may be different underlying
pathophysiology or pathogenesis for some
of these symptoms that still has to be
further understood
but
i think while the data is is is
relatively scant
this emerging data should show that
vaccines are
able to provide a level of protection
against long-covered
some studies put it at 50
effectiveness
that still has to be further studied but
i do think that the vaccine plus
approach is still the way to go
we could do more i think in
communicating
the um the importance of getting
vaccination
uh for the
reduction of the risk of long covert but
as you can you see the data is emerging
if you don't get covalent of course if
you prevent it from getting covered then
you of course
uh have less you don't have a risk of
getting long covered if you didn't get
covered in the first place
so that's
just a fundamental
principle
of
the end of the sixth wave in those
regions we'll see doctor
doctor
come on
so we're in a better situation now than
we were before
and you're mentioning
together
if we look at it
canada
uh
please
cbc news
hi doctors yeah dr tam
in march you said the
government is reviewing all vaccine
mandates including those for federal
public servants and travelers can you
give us an update on
that review what do you think are
mandates here to stay
um i think you best ask the treasury
board president but i i guess
it is my understanding that uh the
review is still ongoing
i want to ask you about the
this mysterious liver disease that we're
seeing reported in some kids hundreds of
cases have been reported worldwide
acute hepatitis i guess is what they're
calling it
what do we know about this and is there
any indication that this is somehow tied
to covid i know in israel some of the
cases that have been reported were in
kids that have had coveted
yes this is
something that globally
there's
been some signals of hepatitis cases
occurring in children
that
we we've been made aware of for sure
and
in canada we've contacted
pediatric hospitals at 17 pediatric
centers to see if we can get a better
understanding of what's going on in
canada
overall i think we're still at the
investigation stage of trying to figure
out whether any of these cases are
indeed linked at all
there's always been hepatitis and and
some severe cases of hepatitis in
children um pre-pandemic and
one would expect post-pandemic as well
and certainly in
the
country similar to canada about 50
percent or thereabouts of pediatric
hepatitis cases are severe have no known
course even before the pandemic
so i think right now we're doing disease
detective work looking at time place
person who is being affected
so that that
investigation is ongoing we've linked
with our provinces we've set our case
report forms and definitions
so
we might expect to hear about some
cases in canada and they'll be called
probable cases because there's no
confirmation as such uh on on the
specific course so it's really casting
the net wide and then homing in to see
if there's any commonalities or common
pathogens i know that in the united
kingdom
and in
alabama and the united states there's
been some detections of
adenovirus type 41 but that may or may
not be
the cause or
the only
factor leading to hepatitis in children
and so i think uh stay tuned of course
we'll provide further information as as
we go along but
we don't have a i don't think we've
solved um
the the underlying cause for these uh
cases at all
yeah
it's dr knew the only additional point i
would add this as dr tam has said is
that
we've worked closely we are working
closely with the provinces and
territories we set up a surveillance
system here in canada and the case
definition we're using is is broad and
similar to the wh show it's you know
really looking at all
uh you know acute hepatitis cases among
individuals less than 16 years of age
casting a wide net and only those that
sort of have been proven to not have
sort of the usual sort of uh
causes you know viruses you know
hepatitis viruses ate and obviously with
obviously uh you know indications of uh
abnormalities inflammation of liver as
you know as a signal by sort of an
increase of liver enzymes so it's quite
a quite a broad case definition and
certainly any of those that we capture
we'll take a closer look with the
experts to see if we can't find a
potentially a common cause but at this
point we're still looking obviously in
canada and we anticipate that there
might be a
situations or cases coming forward that
would meet that broadcast definition
quebec announced
uh
is
individuals
and protect others
uh
uh
and evidence possible to date glenn
mcgregor ctv news
yeah hi uh thanks uh dr tam on the
vaccine mandate for air travelers you've
said in the past that this is an issue
should be decided by policy makers but
they
take your advice on this and say that
they make their decisions based on
science
so
given the limited effectiveness in
vaccination and reducing infections and
the fact that other countries are
abandoning this requirement
what is the rationale for continuing to
require
domestic air travelers to be vaccinated
before boarding and what is your advice
to government on this
so the data is showing that to those is
a vaccine indeed in the omicron wages so
the omicron is the sort of game changer
um has has shifted um the vaccine
effectiveness
and so two doses
has very limited
ability to reduce trans
infection and therefore transmission
and so that is actually very low after
six months but a booster dose of course
boosts that up to
um you know an average that's different
studies different results but an average
of sixty percent uh protection which
also wanes over time so there is no is
not that there is no protection is
imperfect protection um and um which is
why we recommend
layering the masks because the vaccines
alone will not be able to
um completely uh or in a significant way
maybe to reduce
transmission but each of them adds a
layer of protection but it is quite
clear that two doses as is currently
defined in the policies need to be
re-examined
and
so that
those kind of data of course has been
provided to the policy makers
you mentioned uh
the
increase in measles cases reported by
who are we seeing that here
and if so are you concerned that this is
a consequence of
the
politicization of vaccination
over covert 19 spreading to vaccination
against other illnesses i mean are you
seeing declining rates of
vaccination that we've been taking for
decades here in canada and is that
contributing to possible increase in
other illnesses like measles
well i think um the vast majority of
children in canada were vaccinated
against
measles and other
highly contagious infectious diseases
prior to the
pandemic
and so there's always pockets of
vaccine hesitancy lack of vaccine
confidence which we've been tackling
before the pandemic
during the pandemic the issue we are
most concerned with is people
not
having had access to
vaccines during the pandemic needs to
catch up
so
people who were not able to get an
appointment or forgot to get their kids
up to date with a vaccination should do
so now
because as society opens up and there's
increased mixing the risk is going to
increase for all sorts of infectious
diseases that are
transmitted by respiratory roots um and
others and so and people are traveling
so right now we do not have
um
you know reported measles cases but if
people were to travel
that's definitely a risk so definitely
get up to date before travel canada had
eliminated domestic
measles
prior to the pandemic and we need to
keep it that way
but the vast majority of parents and
children are supportive and they've been
vaccinated before i don't see why we
couldn't go back
to get that level of vaccination now
hi there can you hear me yes we can
excel um
uh
foreign
foreign
yeah
um
make sure that you get your next dose um
um
is
and if they are should they wait should
they wait until the end of the summer
um
decreases
uh
perhaps we will see a more targeted
vaccine
canadian press
laura are you able to mute yourself
yeah sorry about that uh good morning
doctors
i wanted to follow up on what my
colleague dylan was asking about juan
covid uh you mentioned that there is a
survey to try to figure out how
widespread this issue is
what are the difficulties in identifying
these people in the health care system
itself um
that we're not able to get those numbers
directly from our health systems and in
the same way that we do with covet cases
for example
um
thank you for the question i think
[Music]
getting
a broader representative um
snapshot is a you know really good
methodology
i think we it should be used alongside
other methods of um you know case
ascertainment
uh there i think given there's a number
of clinics that are being stood up to
um
pay particular attention in the
multidisciplinary to to serve patients
with long covert
those are also centers where uh
information about the cases could come
forth
but
i think this just adds another
methodology to help us gain a broader
and better
look
but i think each of those methods are
supplementary but of course long-covered
symptoms can be quite broad and
non-specific
so depending on the questions and the
questionnaires you might elicit um
different answers so
i think um that that's part of it too
and the survey itself um is
was designed uh to not just
um get at this particular question
but to take another snapshot of the
actual serial prevalence in the
population
and being able to unpack
other
um
disaggregated
information such as of course
uh geographic location but it may help
us understand whether there are
subpopulations
that might be more impacted than others
as well
that's great um
i'm also curious about the implications
for individuals who
might have a hard time identifying
whether they have long covert
particularly if they never received you
know a pcr test or even a rapid test
result
and whether that might have implications
for things like filing
claims for health coverage or time off
work or that sort of thing the fact that
this is difficult to identify what are
some of the implications of that
i think as
all things public health these are very
complex issues and i think the points
that you brought up are very
understandable
i think there's been discussions by
patients with lift living experience
with the relevant departments in charge
of social policies
and
i i think
given the potential lack of data or the
challenges that individuals might have
these need to be taken to account and
make sure that we do have equitable
access and
and to care and support for individual
patients
i do think it would be quite difficult
to seize out in the study contexts
when we are looking at several
prevalence for example
um
there are different methodologies with
antibody
responses more than one tests are being
applied to try and get a better handle
on whether people got past infections
so so with that in mind we'll get i i
think the survey
will give us a better understanding of
of the application of really what has
been sort of research tools in antibody
uh data on past infections and maybe
even out of that there could be more
diagnostic
tools um that could be
useful
for people with long covid or
potentially have long covered
we do need actual diagnostics and that's
what the research um is all about is to
find actual diagnostics or markers
for long-covered
impacts
bonjour
can you hear me
yes we can
concern
uh
is
[Music]
uh
um
in public
other people could be immunity
what is your recommendation
a few minutes left to the press
conference uh we we might have time for
maybe one question uh if you have
additional questions so just raise your
hand and let me know but we also have a
heart stop at
noon so uh
um
um
vaccinations
dylan roberts oh hi dr tan uh the fact
dashboard does not seem to list forced
doses yet you mentioned last time that
forced doses are starting to outpace the
growth in third doses so i'm wondering
what your understanding is of how many
fourth doses have been administered and
why the information isn't posted on
facts website yet
um
i
can't answer the last question as to why
is not posted
um i think
we have most of the information as far
as i know i i will have to i don't have
the numbers in front of me but i have
seen them
in some jurisdictions it takes a bit of
time to separate those numbers as to
whether they are first second third or
fourth dose i know that that sometimes
there is a lag
but that information should be available
but i haven't
personally checked the website
in in terms of the
the
gap that you identified so we'll follow
up on that
but yes fourth dose
uh seem to be some of the
responsible for a majority of the
increase in vaccine administered in
recent weeks
and glenn mcgregor ctv news
uh yeah just following up with my
previous question about the vaccine
mandate for domestic air travel
you said two doses are showing uh you
know greatly diminished effectiveness
are you suggesting that a booster dose a
third or fourth dose should be
considered as a requirement for air
travel by the government
um i believe the relevant departments
are looking at a range of options and i
don't think they've made any uh
decisions on that front so we've
provided that information but there are
many other factors to consider when
one is making a policy in terms of uh
feasibility
of rollout um and uh and many other
factors and i think they should also
examine um ethical factors and and and
and there's always a balance between
um
you know the
scientific foundation of course but
there's many other considerations
um as departments try to figure this out
as a matter of policy
but i think from my perspective i just
want to make sure
that whichever way this goes people
don't forget that vaccines are important
as provinces lifted their mandates
one of the concerns is that people
suddenly think oh well in that case we
don't have to
think about vaccinations and that has to
be really well managed
in terms of communications
and our last question is going to mr
tasker
yeah thanks doctors um as you might have
seen the us fda put
strict limits on the use of the johnson
and johnson vaccine today because of the
risk of thrombosis with thrombocytopedia
um i know you folks aren't the regulator
but what's what's your opinion on this
and the other viral vector shot
astrazeneca given what the u.s
regulators have said about them
yes um i think from a canadian
perspective there won't need to be any
changes and health canada is satisfied
right now with the labeling of the
vaccine they don't answer any changes
following the fda announcements
this i think any safety signal must be
taken seriously we've known about
thrombosis with thrombocytopenia
syndrome for some time the national
advisory committee on immunization in
canada
well over a year ago had recommended the
mrna vaccine over
preferentially compared to uh jensen and
astrazeneca vaccine and one of the key
considerations is uh the rare occurrence
of some of these uh adverse events
so in the canadian context um in the in
the us they used i really you know
eight million doses uh administered in
the united states in canada we had
administered 40 000 doses a very small
number compared to the i think
now 83 million doses that we've
administered in canada there's been no
cases of
this particular clotting syndrome
reported in canada following this small
number of
doses because it's a rare occurrence i
think
so we don't expect a lot of changes in
our recommendations
and uh this is all the time we have
session
thank you very much have a great weekend
thank you
thank you